Betty Shabazz a remarkable story of
survival and faith before and after
Malcolm X this talk lasts an hour 15
minutes well we're here at at sister
space and books at 15th and you this
fantastic bookstore that I've been
hearing so much about over the last few
years I guess they've been at this
location for six years I'm Russell
Rickford I'm the author of Betty Shabazz
a remarkable story of survival and faith
before and after Malcolm X that long
subtitle wasn't my idea so but this is
the first I guess serious biography of
dr. Shabazz who as some of you will
remember it passed away in the summer of
1997 tragically in that fire that was
actually set by her grandson who was
adolescent I think was around 13 at the
time he is the son of her second
daughter Kabila and she has six
daughters so let's see I am 28 I started
the book when I was about 25 so it was
certainly a struggle being young and
being a man and being a non-muslim
dealing with some of these some of the
communities in which dr. Shabazz moved
and some of the circles in which he
moved certainly there was I think a
degree of skepticism or certainly
caution whoa who is this guy trying to
do a story about sister Betty dr. Betty
but eventually I think I overcame that
because people figured out that okay
this brothers motives are actually
honorable and he's really trying to do a
good job and then they realized that I
knew something about Malcolm I didn't
know nothing about dr. Betty but I knew
a lot about Malcolm and I was willing to
do the work the research initially I
actually agreed to do the book and in
2000 I had done a book with my dad on
black English
title spoken soul the story of Black
English basically about Ebonics and out
of that my agent I had with that book he
introduced me to this idea of doing a
book about dr. Shabazz and I agreed
because I was so into Malcolm always had
been into Malcolm since I was in high
school I think like a lot of brothers
and sisters of my generation we were
attracted to Malcolm in the in the late
80s and early 90s you know hip-hop
started sampling his uh his speeches and
he started hearing him and a lot of rap
songs and I think one of the reasons was
that well there was a several different
reasons I mean basically at a time where
there was we felt like there was really
a crisis of black leadership there
wasn't a lot of very strong black
leaders speaking out for the issues that
we that were important to us here was a
voice and a message that we could really
attach ourselves to you know that he
felt like he was speaking to our needs
in dealing with neoconservatism and
Reagan presidency and the Bush
presidency and and white racism and how
we just kept going and going so in any
case I think that what I discovered in
researching dr. Shabazz is that it was a
mistake to come to approach her life
just in terms of Malcolm okay because
when I started I was really looking at
her almost as an extension of Malcolm
and and I was seeing the value of her
story in terms of getting to know more
about Malcolm's family life and then by
extension learning more about his
political ideals pretty early on in the
research I realized that that wasn't
going to work that this was a compelling
valuable story in its own right that she
wasn't a a fascinating figure in her own
right and that her story needed to be
paid its respect and I need to give her
her due and once I figured that
I think it was a lot I'm not gonna say
it was easy but certainly I understood
maybe the significance of what I was
trying to do and so I think what her
story I mean the telling of her story I
think feels an important gap in black
history in women's history in American
history I think that in many profound
ways the story of her survival after
Malcolm's assassination is 65 she lived
from 65 to 97 really mirrors a lot of
the both the victories and the defeats
and the crises in the black community
and black leadership and what's going on
in black neighborhoods black urban
neighborhoods all of those good bad and
ugly is reflected in her story in the
story of her family so let me start
reading before I mess around and talk
too much this first scene is from
Valentine's Day 1965 this is a week
before Malcolm's assassination sister
Betty and brother Malcolm have been
married at this point for seven years
okay they were actually married
January 14th 1958 so this is not a
February 14 65 Betty and Malcolm
sleeping soundly he had flown in from
London worn and edgy and had gulped a
sedative
she had tucked in the children and gone
to bed slipping beneath sheets and
layers of fear Malcolm was slumbering
upstairs in his study that night as he
often did but he had gotten so many
threatening calls that day if she
wondered whether she was having a
nervous breakdown
more horrors lay ahead a 2:45 a.m.
fracturing glass and an explosion
shattered the night as the first Molotov
cocktail hit within seconds black smoke
was turning and orange tentacles of
flames were skimming along the floor and
flitting up the walls
Malcolm was vaulting out of bed and
pounding through the house toward the
children as the second fire bomb struck
betty ledin with pregnant pregnancy she
was pregnant with twins at the time
staggered into the hallway and found
herself near the kitchen door
she heard the thud as a third Molotov
cocktail glanced off a rear window and
fizzled get the girls she thought but
the linoleum seemed to have swallowed
her up to her shins then Malcolm was
flinging open the back door and barking
at her stay here he plunged into the
clotting smoke scooping up shrieking
children the older three from a bedroom
beside his and Betty's and Gamila from
her crib nearby in an instant he
returned and deposited them at Betty's
side their incandescent phases jolted
her from her trance still in her
nightgown she hustled the bawling girls
into the yard again Malcolm bounded into
the house now for some of their
belongings soon when he re-emerged in
his under clothes and a singed overcoat
joining his wife and children in the
frigid darkness they stood there
coughing and shivering their eyes
stinging as firemen battled the leaping
blaze the flames would incinerate almost
half of the uninsured house but his
occupants were alive kabila who had been
the first child awake and who screams
may have roused her parents sobbed
beside her sisters she was for the age
Malcolm had been when white men torched
his family's Omaha Nebraska home in 1929
it was an episode he described in his
autobiography I remember being suddenly
snatched awaken to a frightening
confusion of pistol-shots he wrote and
shouting and smoke and flames my father
had shouted and shot at the two white
men who had set the fire and were
running away our home was burning down
around us we were lunging and bumping
and tumbling all over each other trying
to escape my mother with her baby in her
arms just made it into the yard before
the house crashed in showering sparks
now 36 years later it was Betty who
struggled to comfort her children as
flames swallowed the home they had only
just escaped
I was almost frightened by his courage
and efficiency in a time of terror she
later said of Malcolm I always knew he
was strong but at that hour I learned
how great his strength was the minister
was so composed that even his eldest
daughter had not fully grasped the
danger my mother's like that too
Lala later said together what Betty
never forgot her own paralysis she had
been useless as a corpse in the few
precious moments that might have meant
her children's lives and she vowed never
again to
freeze in the face of danger numbness
harver yielded swiftly to rage I
couldn't imagine anybody being that
cruel she said later I couldn't imagine
that anyone who claim to love black
people
could do something like that she
wondered how an order that preached love
for God race and family could so despise
a man who honored all three with body
and soul
Malcolm thought it was the black Muslims
- when a reporter screeched onto the
scene and asked whom he thought had
torched the place his only reply was a
peal of bitter half crazed laughter the
Malcolm ice assured the Malcolm i'ts the
Malcolm followers assured a distraught
Betty and her daughters to the house of
Wu biddies brother Tom Wallace a dear
friend and Oh AAU member who lived
nearby in Queens Malcolm did not
accompany them he was scheduled to speak
in Detroit later that day and spent the
next few hours preparing to catch a
morning flight he could almost hear the
countdown to his death but he was
determined not to bow to his enemies
there was still much to say him do
having barely escaped death by fire
alongside her husband and daughters
Betty discovered that Malcolm planned to
keep his out of town speaking date and
flew into a rage
this last injustice charred whatever
sliver of her composure had survived the
flames later that Valentine's Day a
fatigued and tormented Malcolm stood
before Detroit audience and closed that
wreaked of smoke and proclaimed that the
bombing had not sapped his resolve quote
because my wife understands and I have
children from this sighs on down and
even in their young age they understand
but neither Betty's fear nor her fury
had kept the minister in New York so I
think in that passage there are some
signs of some of the strains that the
marriage had gone through particularly
in that last year after Malcolm broke
with an honorable elijah muhammad and
went off on his own there's a lot of
pressure from the black Muslims there's
a lot of heat of course from the FBI the
CIA the intelligence community and betty
was dealing with all of that pressure
mostly on her own because Malcolm has
spent most of that year overseas in
Africa and the Middle East I think he
always felt guilty for not being the the
husband and father that he would have
liked to have been
and certainly this was a source of deep
pain and trauma for dr. Shabazz so a
week after this episode with the
firebombing Malcolm is assassinated
before Betty's eyes but I think it's
important for us to remember that there
had been she had suffered a lot of
trauma and a lot of pain even before the
assassination even though there are
signs that there were some happy moments
in the marriage you know brother Malcolm
was almost never there she was dealing
with a lot of pressure she was dealing
with the sexism of the rate of the
nation in Islam Malcolm's own you know
sexism and also he was an authoritarian
leader and in many ways an authoritarian
husband let's see I want to read you
something for just from just a few hours
after the assassination women within the
Nation of Islam
it was straight trained I mean I think
that you know being the first lady and
in a sense she was the first lady I mean
you know of course Elijah Muhammad is
the leader and so his wife sister Clara
I guess formally would be the first lady
but Malcolm was the most popular
minister and Malcolm was the brother
that in the black community was widely
known especially after 59 and and
certainly after 59 he was most known in
in a white mainstream in the media and
college campuses this sort of thing so
the point is that she was the sister
that they love to hate now there are
other reasons for that tension I think
that she had a very strong forceful
personality so she was dealing with the
patriarchy of the nation in Islam with
their chauvinism she was dealing with
you know jealousy from the sisters she
later on she would tell her daughters
about some sisters would come by the
house with with the bean pie or
something loa 'kiss we know how Minister
Malcolm likes this pie and you know so
she was very suspicious of that now some
sisters in a nation who I talked to
thought that she was too suspicious
but you have to understand with all the
pressures that she was dealing with
taking care of those children her
husband away oversees all the time and I
mean Malcolm was was ascetic I mean we
know for instance there's been
information that's come out about Martin
and other women but Malcolm was an
ascetic in the sense that he wasn't into
that you know extracurricular activities
you know but sister Betty was still very
nervous about that and there were a lot
of problems with their own relationship
from early on some of which stem from I
think Malcolm's great suspicion about
women you know Malcolm he was one of the
strongest preachers in the nation Islam
talking about protecting sisters I'm
talking about kind of the purity of
black women but it was kind of a
double-edged sword because on one hand
sisters were supposed to be so pure and
untouchable and you know the Paragons of
womanhood in lady hood but on the other
hand he wanted them to stay in the
kitchen stay raising the children you
know and this was a time just before the
feminist movement and black black woman
a woman ISM and Afrikaner Womanism
everything that happened in the early
70s late 60s sister body could have been
very much part of that she was educated
much more educated than most of the
sister the Nation of Islam when she
married Malcolm in 58
she had a nursing degree she'd been in
Tuskegee
she'd been in nursing school and so the
fact that he would not allow her to work
was another one of the I think crises of
the of the marriage I don't want to
portray him as just authoritarian and I
don't want to put all the problems in
the marriage on him because certainly I
think her personality both her I think
legitimate desire to work outside of the
home and to express you know the talents
and the knowledge and skills that she
had gained in school and also her
forceful personality her will her will
to be an independent woman
you know Malcolm wasn't having that so
let me read this briefly this passage
that's happening a few hours after the
assassination at the wallace's this is a
friend of the families that live nearby
the Wallis's the smell of fresh coffee
wafted from the kitchen where women were
fixing drinks for the mob of visitors
and the evening meal for mountains
family a woman crouched with three of
the shahboz daughters in the dining room
excuse me quietly helping them practice
the alphabet that's a lot ventured into
the living room and found a newswoman
settling by her side
the intent child showed the grown-up how
to teach her children the alphabet the
reporter obligingly printed her name
with finicky plot block letters the girl
did the same this is for you to keep for
your own out till I told her don't
forget to teach the children the phone
jangled puncturing the children's sue
serrations and the grown-up staring
silent small TV set blathered on the
couch surrounded by the survivors
including for the men who had sworn to
defend her husband with their lives sat
Betty she looked at a journalist friend
nearby they've taken him away from me
mrs. Wilson she said her eyes wide his
wounds later that evening with the
cordon of her husband's stunned
disciples beside her and her two eldest
girls nestled at her side Betty watched
the television review of the minister's
stormy life Malcolm glint glinted on the
screen unconquered ball again it was too
much for the widow she found her feet
and wandered into the kitchen a
strapping man nearby whispered tell him
like it is brother Malcolm tell him tell
him like it is Betty stood staring at
the wall is daddy coming back after a
speech mama that's a lot asked the widow
wrapped her arms around the child as her
head dropped near the refrigerator
four-year-old Kabila tub tugged at her
mother's skirt please don't go out mama
Betty guided the girls head into her lap
I won't go baby she said softly Ella
Collins
this is Malcolm's older half-sister I'd
her sister-in-law a woman almost twenty
years her junior from somewhere nearby
suddenly she was proud of Betty and the
grace with which she had sued with the
children kabila was the only Shabazz
daughter who seemed to realize that her
father was not coming home at salaah had
expected Malcolm to spring to his feet
after he toppled onto the Audubon stage
once assured heard that the gun down
Cowboys on televisions Bonanza we're
only pretending to be dead but dr. Lyle
was starting to understand before sleep
overtook her she plopped down with their
marker and scrawled a note dear daddy I
love you so oh dear oh dear I wish she
wasn't dead meanwhile Betty huddled with
photographer and writer Gordon Parks in
the kitchen she told him that she'd been
ready for her husband's death she was
ashamed that she had cried over him when
he was lying there all shot up
he was always away the widow said but I
knew he would always come back we loved
each other
he was honest too honest for his own
good I sometimes think Gordon Parks
started to wander off I only hope that
the child I'm carrying is just like his
father
Betty added I hope you get your wish
Park said later that night the widow
prepared to leave for a meeting with
Sutton Percy Sutton who with his brother
Oliver would offer solace and legal
counsel in the days and years ahead
she gritted against tears offering a few
farewells to the congregated visitors as
she headed out the door thank you for
coming she whispered goodbye I'm deeply
touched Sutton was beside her when
swallowed and grief she arrived at
nearby supper club in a cell in East
Elmhurst she lingered for a minute or
two before the roll of reporters
tearfully recounting her husband's
ominous wake-up call that morning then
Sutton took over Malcolm X died broke he
announced he said the minister had
pumped every penny of his outside
earnings into black Islam and into his
Muslim and nationalist camps thereafter
the succinct media conference wrapped up
and Betty was moving again she wanted to
surrender to the shadows to let the
creeping paralysis in golfer but the
fares of the dead and the living
clamored for her attention later on that
fall sister Betty gave birth to twins
Mallika and Malak bringing her children
to six six daughters and this was a
rough time because you know as I said
Malcolm hadn't broke
and she had urged Malcolm to put aside
some money for the family in the years
in which he had been the top Minister
for Elijah Muhammad but Malcolm always
refused saying that you know the
messenger will take care of us the
messenger will take care of us and
sister Betty I think was suspicious of
Elijah Muhammad's motives and his
personal life long before Malcolm would
allow himself to see the truth so as a
result there was no money after Malcolm
died there was a few hundred dollars in
a bank account
and there was a group of women including
Ruby d18 of Poitier Sidney Poitier's
wife and a few other sisters mostly
middle-class Christian sisters prominent
sisters actresses and activists and this
sort of thing who came together and
actually supported sister Betty in those
first couple of years without them you
know who knows what she would have done
there was also of course a lot of
working-class black folk who put $2 in
an envelope for $2 or $5 one brother
sent some money said buy milk for from
Malcolm's babies so it was both the milk
this very small cadre within the black
middle class and also many you know more
anonymous black working-class people who
made sure that this family survived
interestingly enough that fall sister
Betty and the children moved into Mount
Vernon north of New York City which was
in a black neighborhood had many black
neighborhoods and she moved to a kind of
a well-to-do neighborhood black
neighborhood but there were a lot of
tensions even for her the wife and
family of Malcolm X moving into this
probably black area Mount Vernon did not
want her not black bushwa Mount Vernon
anyway when Betty moved there the
community was very very upset her cousin
Ruth Summerford later said most White's
lived on the north side the
working-class south side was largely
black but college-bred blacks were
displacing White's in the heights a few
years after the widow led her daughter's
into a corner house in the posh
neighborhood the local kids without a
hint of irony
took the calling of the Renee the
remaining white families pilgrims mrs.
Malcolm X's new neighbors were Dennis
lawyers
clergymen and celebrities jazz diva Nina
Simone live two blocks away many of them
cringed at the prospect of a notorious
militant survivors in their midst with
the newcomers sullied The Enclave and
its middle-class integrationist
sensibilities would Malcolm's daughter's
radicalized the children some of the
brown brahmins were did not intend to
wait and see as the word spread in the
fall of 65 that Betty and family were
coming to town there was talk of a
petition to stop the sale of Bella zoogs
old place and one or more gadflies began
collecting signatures Mount Vernon was
no racial Haven as the Shabazz were
settling in local n-double-a-cp pickets
marched on City Hall demanding
integrated schools and decent housing on
the south side yet while white in
resistance to integration was an
irritation for Mount Vernon's
african-american middle class a threat
to respectability was a full full-blown
crisis most of the black professionals
wanted nothing to do with Malcolm's
legacy Lawrence Otis Graham a grade
school classmate of Attila and Kabila
later remembered some of the elites
spurned Betty others ignored her the
first people who reached out to me in
Mount Vernon were white the widow later
told a mentor black hostility and
ignorance simmered throughout that first
year Kabila said a society wife one
afternoon outside the local private
school the elder Shabazz daughters
attended what kind of a name is that
another mother waited for a child shy
waiting for a child chimed in I think
it's Islam or Muslims something like
that she said Betty managed a frail
smile and stared her girls into their
designated seats in the back of the blue
Oldsmobile she had inherited from her
husband there was white animosity but it
was despite within her race that
embittered the widow were these a Negros
for whom Malcolm had died nor was
Malcolm's mystique less burdensome than
his stigma some of the privilege blacks
delighted in stunning black cronies with
the news that mrs. Malcolm X and company
lived around the way
few of the locals were openly malicious
most whispered out of curiosity or
anxiety and the widow maintained a web
of black support
besides chattering neighbors could not
spoil the neighborhood's charm stately
colonial squatted on hills and light
traffic buzzed on shaded streets lawns
were lush and rimmed with clouds of
shrubbery and staircases unfurled from
porches even the garages were eerie the
black residents were lettered and their
kids were college bound drenched in ivy
the Shabazz house anchor East 5th and
cedar which ended in a sprawling wood
wooded area here was the upper middle
class dome that Betty had longed for
throughout her marriage the kind of
comfort Malcolm himself had known only
during his wandering teen years with
Ella Collins a self-made member of
Boston's landed black aristocracy the
widow later recalled that the
assassination had had left her life in
bits and pieces
Mount Vernon seemed an ideal place to
mend the grief did not dissolve so much
as slacking only to constrict every
night after the children fell asleep
they drove it away each morning with
their clamoring for cereal but the rest
bits were brief and often joyless that
Malcolm was gone still seemed absurd it
was two years before Betty could bring
him bring herself to hang his portraits
about the house when we did put the
pictures up I thought that we had
finally reached the point where we could
talk about him without tears she said in
1969 but now I doubt this will ever
happen
the children were scarred too they knew
only that something terrible had
happened
Betty later said Attila kabila and Neil
Yassa had seen at least two attempts on
their father's life
it's the firebombing and the actual
assassination the peril had seeped too
deep into their consciousness for Betty
to fully absorb in the early years the
girls cried not just for their father
but out of a shattered sense of security
during trances that spooked her
playmates aunt Ella relived the flaming
house and the tumult of gunfire
for years she wondered if the army that
had executed her father would return for
the rest of her family the girls there
were so many shots they sounded to them
like it was an army as a second grader
she sometimes walked into the classroom
and plunked down in her seat with the
codons
blankly after a while she later said you
get to thinking how dare they how dare
they take my father from me
kabila would not confront that rage for
years on the fourth anniversary of her
father's death the precocious child then
seven scrawled an essay titled Malcolm X
a black leader on a 4x6 card and handed
it to her mother the details and grammar
were off but the sentiment was crushing
she wrote Malcolm X was a brave leader
he fought for rights for all black
people his black preachings were in
everybody's heart in 1964 he was at the
Audubon preaching and everyone was
listening instead of falling asleep
listening to his black word then for not
long he was shot he died but his black
beautiful soul is in every black
person's heart this is a in the early
70s and actually throughout her her
daughter's early childhood
dr. Shabazz really struggled to shelter
them from a lot of different things but
mostly from I think some of the
political legacies of her husband she
wanted to shelter them from the kind of
radicalism because she knew what that
radicalism had cost her family
the Shabazz daughters could not truly
appreciate who their father was
politically because Betty never told
them I taught them about him by me being
disciplined and strict she later said my
children think my persona is me when
actually it is their father's the
children grew up among his relics many
of the well thumbed volumes in the
family library had been his his hat and
suitcase sat in a closet one found
souvenirs from his travels in various
nooks and his bespectacled face peered
out lessly
I wish Lee from portraits on the walls
still the girls reached their teens with
little understanding of Malcolm as one
of the century's prescient
revolutionaries they had no clue one of
their playmates later said in time they
realized that betty was a symbol for
people throughout the world they were
curious about her trips abroad and
sensitive to the manner in which
Outsiders approached her they washed her
cache
cachet of dashikis African headdresses
foreign currency books gifts and
mementos from friends and admirers grow
meanwhile they clung to the vestiges of
daddy that they had always known the
stories and the proud sense that he had
been utterly devoted to his people at
Salah who had the clearest memory of him
was their sisters ligament - their
father
she and Betty still spoke of him as if
he had just gone out for a newspaper
Hill Yasha later said yet Attila could
not talk about Malcolm the warrior and
Betty wouldn't in my father's absence my
mother nurtured and protected the
significance and value of her husband's
endless devotion to human rights the
eldest daughter said but though
youngsters across the country were
plunging into his autobiography the
widow never discussed the book with her
children aunt Ella was a teenager before
she realized that she was more
intimately linked to the characters in
her father's memoirs and to those in the
Swiss Family Robinson old friends would
reminisce about him during visits
transfixing his daughters with tales of
razor wit and charm or his boundless
energy
the girls were hungry for ballads and
parables and anecdotes
they never tired of listening to their
father's character witnesses still the
narratives seemed biblically ancient and
distant from their reality we just
briefly read I think one more quick
passage this talks a little bit about
dr. Shabazz struggles with men and
dating in the years after Malcolm there
were a few people that kind of were her
escorts to different public events in
the early years after Malcolm's
assassination but there was so much
pressure on her to remain single or not
to remarry or not to have a boyfriend
and also she was very very suspicious of
any man or anybody really coming into
life of her and her children I mean she
had to be you know I think as I
mentioned the threats to her family did
not stop after Malcolm's assassination
and now we know that the FBI did not
stop monitoring dr. Shabazz until
probably the mid-70s or later so almost
12 years after Malcolm's assassination
the FBI was still spying on on Betty and
the girls
Betty missed the girls missed that her
daughters while they were away but a
time she was lonely even while their
giggles echoed through the house she
longed from Malcolm for the enveloping
warmth of belonging to somebody though
she had arrived at social affairs with
various escorts in her early widowhood
she had not seriously considered
remarrying I can't even think about
marriage because Tamara would be to
admit that Malcolm is really dead and
although I know he's gone I don't want
the break to be so final she once said
she thought even a serious relationship
unlikely the girl she said occupied 99%
of her time besides she felt too damaged
for romance her artist clique urged she
used to hang out with some artists
including Nikki Giovanni her artist
clique urged her to remarry to ease the
grief loneliness and financial burdens
she just laughed no one seemed to
understand the force of Malcolm's
lingering presence for her he was there
and his goals drove off suitors the
saintliness of public widowhood and
Betty's suspicion of those who hazarded
advances made her no more approachable
for all her fierce independence she also
feared black America's disapproval
people don't want me to have a boyfriend
she once told Amina Baraka jokingly it's
a amiri baraka 'he's wife friends
strangers and journalists were forever
asking the widow if she was going to get
hitched again she allowed only a dim
possibility in the distant future for a
time she said no so violently that
people wondered whether whether
something had gone wrong between her and
Malcolm she may actually have declined
at least one formal proposal early in
her widowhood a colleague later
confronted her with the rumor that
Muammar al-gaddafi leader of the Islamic
state of Libya had extended his hand to
her as an act of chivalry in those lean
years could be Betty replied with
typical coyness but I'm not about being
part of a harem my biggest fight is
being alone
Betty once confessed she kidded about
the predicament
say rev why don't the fellas flirt with
me she asked a comrade he pondered this
for a moment I think you got this
atmosphere about you that says look but
don't touch he replied
sometimes Betty could not laugh away the
solitude when the children were asleep
are away when she could not ring her
female friends because the phone would
wake their husband's loneliness clasped
her like a noose
I wouldn't wish her life on anybody the
meal of her fourth daughter later said
is being married to my father seven
years enough to carry you for the rest
of your life there were gentlemen
callers of course one even managed to
win her heart eventually she broke it
off no doubt there were many
complications but it didn't help that he
started smoking pot always a fetching
and shapely woman the widow began
gaining weight food was a fleeting
solace you had nothing could soothe her
a few years later when the man returned
he marched up to the front porch rang
the doorbell and started pacing
nervously betty was horrified she
thought she had grown fat I'm rushing to
leave she shouted through the door then
began crying softly the visitors stood
on the porch for a few minutes staring
at the door finally he whispered okay
Betty and left face I do one more
because I take questions I said the
woman quick passage let me take one do
one more really brief passage that that
takes a little bit takes it into the 90s
Betty left in upstate New York fasting
retreat the afternoon the premier with a
supply of apple beet and carrot juice
for the tribe to Manhattan what she
really wanted was a glass of wine she
told herself that she could handle this
she did her deep breathing exercises
nothing worked I was going to see my
husband and I wouldn't be able to bring
him home she later said the evening was
a swirl of anxiety and anticipation
finally she arrived at the premiere
Diana Ross Bobby Brown Stevie Wonder
Whitney Houston and Madonna traipsed
across the red carpet yet Betty had eyes
for only one star my girls and I were
going to see my husband she said and
Denzel is he tonight minutes later
minutes later she was sitting in the
theater marveling and angela bassett
sport rail
of a young Muslim woman whose shimmering
confidence enthralled Malcolm a woman
the widow did not recognize she went
straight to the bullseye
Betty later said a Bassets character
chuckling at the idea that the minister
would have succumbed to so forthright a
woman then the more harrowing scenes
began to roll
Betty felt her composure crumbling her
hands began drifting over her head
Elia ASSA caught them and coaxed them
down south it's all right honey the
third Shabazz daughter cooed I'm here
serious Malcolm i'ts lamb basted the
movie former Oh ay ay you man herbin
Ferguson groused
that Spike Lee's Malcolm had wound up an
accommodationist first they assassinated
the messenger he said now they're
attempting to assassinate the message
doctor to dr. John Henry Clark the
inattention to the minister's bond with
Kwame Nkrumah and other third world
revolutionaries was tantamount to making
lemonade without lemons you have sweet
water the elder said but you can't call
it lemonade still box office registers
were singing as were black notables from
Reverend Al Sharpton to Bobby Seale
Spike Lee has made a great contribution
to history Jesse Jackson said though he
worried that mythology was clouding
Malcolm's meaning if Betty had similar
concerns she swallowed them no movie
could capture Malcolm she said but she
called the Lee effort an excellent
introduction she dismissed charges that
frivolity drenched the pictures early
sequences
Malcolm was such a serious subject that
one might welcome a little light
heartedness she said recalling that
satire had been central to her husband's
pedagogy she acknowledged that Malcolm X
the movie was just a silhouette what can
you show in three hours she said that
she generally avoided appraising the
film during interviews even as temperate
stance Malcolm X's appetizer vexed some
of the movie's detractors including some
of Malcolm's siblings who saw the
martyr's commodification as wholesale
betrayal Ella Collins who who was among
those who charged Spike Lee with
profiteering now a 77 year old diabetic
and double amputee living in a nursing
home she revived her ancient feud with
Betty by questioning the widow's grasp
of her late husband's politics
doesn't know enough about Malcolm to
consult on anything Colin said she would
go to certain places and hear him speak
but her activities were very limited she
was having babies I don't have any
respect for that lady Betty shot back
months before the pictures release
several of Malcolm's other siblings had
also expressed a league their misgivings
about Betty's association with the
project Betty paid the rumblings no mind
she was caught up in the reverie her
Malcolm was back and all of a sudden he
was beloved she had always sworn by the
African proverb that says call an
ancestors name every day and he shall
live forever
now the minister's presence enveloped
her again wedged in manehattan traffic
one afternoon before the film premiere
she spotted a man in X regalia I like
your shirt she shouted flashing a thumbs
up thank you sister the man replied with
a grin but he ignored the symbolism
versus substance debate that had
embroiled the film one of her allies
thought that the picture's flaws ripped
and tore at her but the widow had never
fashioned herself as a custodian of her
husband's ideological purity and felt no
obligation to distance herself from the
spectacle of the Malcolm X movie Betty
had worried that the film would unearth
her in the ministers domestic warfare or
portray him quote like some wimp she was
unhappy that the product that the
finished product lacked scenes of the
family man frolicking with his wife and
kids the benign figure she and her
eldest daughters had so industriously
promoted but she was willing to buy more
grievous historical flaws in exchange
for the respectability and wealth that
Malcolm X the movie would generate for
her family and the glory that it would
lavish upon Malcolm she endured the
frivolities of hero worship for a
similar return so what so what so what
so what she said of the orgy of Malcolm
X merchandise insisting that the fashion
craze which stare youngsters toward a
deeper knowledge of her husband no one
gets a book and starts at the last
chapter she said in the end she was
right despite its failings Malcolm X the
movie revived Malcolm more powerfully
than a thousand Street ceremonies and
wolf threads of his political thought
into the orthodoxy of a new generation
this was Betty's year of Malcolm no one
who knew her still
could blame her for basking she had
sworn long ago that the world would
someday celebrate him Myrlie
evers-williams the widow of medgar evers
fallen her the morning of the premiere
to remind her of that pledge this is the
day Murli announced I told you Betty
said quietly and someday they will
recognize medgar thank you go ahead
relationship between dr. Betty Shabazz
in in Coretta Scott King that you know
uh that you can speak up sure oh you
know I guess I had to go back to Malcolm
you know Malcolm for years I mean he
didn't really like he didn't like any of
the civil rights leaders he thought they
were all bunk but the person who really
got in his narrows was Martin because he
felt like Martin was pacifying the black
masses when they needed to be more
militant against attacks on black
community black women and children etc
towards the end of his life towards the
mid 60s
Malcolm began to get I think more savvy
about the role he could play visa vie
the civil rights movement and the fact
that some of the goals were not that
different their strategies were just
different and in fact he started taking
a more of a conciliatory stance toward
King I hesitate to say that because he
still to the end of his life disagreed
with King's objectives I mean King
wanted you know integration and equal
opportunity when Malcolm really wanted
the United Nations to charge the United
States with violating black people's
human rights I mean so he wanted black
Malcolm wanted black people in the
United States to hook up with
revolutionaries in the third world to
mount a kind of worldwide revolution
against white supremacy and global
oppression but you'll remember that a
couple months before his death Malcolm
actually went down into the south to
speak to some of Kings representatives
and he would have met with King had King
I've been in jail at the time so
Betty I think in the late 60s and early
70s began I think she first met Coretta
in 1970 and they would meet at various
public events they would meet on the
dais of National black political
conventions in 1970 1972 and in Gary
Indiana
and I think they were always it was kind
of a formality they were fairly pleasant
certainly they understood the importance
of keeping up appearances you know and
how important they were symbolically to
black people into the movement but I
think there was a lot of tension there
particularly felt by Betty one of the
biggest reasons was that well first
thing we have to understand is that you
know Carretas experience have been
totally different mrs. King's experience
have been totally different she had been
universally almost universally embraced
by America by the world really after
Mount Martin's assassination she had the
opportunity to kind of retreat for a
while and to write her autobiography and
sign a very you know big book contract
to do so sister Betty didn't have any of
those opportunities those privileges she
was still fighting for her life in the
life of her children and Malcolm was
seen in the mainstream and by much of
the black establishment as a pariah so
in the early 1980s when for instance the
movement to make King's birthday a
holiday he really started getting going
and when they finally signed the
legislation ironically under Reagan dr.
Shabazz at that time she was a doctor
she wanted for Malcolm all of that
admiration and she you know there was
always a group of people within a black
community that loved Malcolm there was
army and mostly was people working-class
people people in the urban north
radicals young militants young
intellectuals young artists who for him
for them you know he was their hero but
Malcolm was never universally embraced
by black people even though I think many
from the black middle class his idea
resonated with them and they were kind
of secretly liked or admires some of the
things he said
but Betty wanted respectability she
wanted it for herself she wanted it for
her daughters and she wanted it for her
husband and so that I think was a source
of some of the tension between them you
know this one activist I talked to
talked about how in the earlier of
mid-70s sister Betty and and mrs. King
would be at the same event and mrs. King
would have her whole entourage with her
and she'd have her speechwriters and
she'd pulled out her speak you know
sister Betty would be by herself
pulling her speech out of her bag and
it'd be written on the back of a napkin
you know sister Betty and mrs. King
eventually became very close friends but
it didn't happen
I think until and I'm not sure if this
is a direct correlation but I think it
helped until Malcolm began to get more
of the recognition and from the
mainstream you know sister Betty would
never dr. Shabazz would never live to
see the Malcolm X postal stamp although
she she campaigned for it
it's beginning the 80s but she would
have loved it I think I mean because
this is the type of recognition she
wanted for Malcolm
eventually in 1995 I have a letter that
mrs. King sent dr. Shabazz in 95 couple
years before dr. Shabazz of death in
which mrs. King says hey how you doing
sister it's a very like you know
girlfriendy type of conversation sister
you know it's been so long here's the
hand cream I promised I would send you
happy mother's day and here's you know
they all the strange flowers on Mother's
Day and dr. Shabazz was so proud of that
letter she passed it around all of her
friends and look what look what Retta
sent me you know she was very proud of
that so eventually that relationship
became really powerful and it was very
amiri baraka told me that he remember
once being at some event you know they
would go to these annual retreats or
biannual retreats with a lot of you know
black leaders and sister Betty and mrs.
King sometimes would be there and one
time they were huddling together in the
corner and he looked over and he was
moved almost to tears looking at these
you know at these two symbols he's two
icons and thinking about the fact that
their husbands never
were able to get together even though in
many ways they kind of wanted to it was
still suspicious of each other but they
were both cut down before they could get
together but their widows ended up
getting together that was very
meaningful you refer to her as the widow
I guess interchangeably with Betty and I
was wondering why she wouldn't just
stand on her own as Betty or dr. Shabazz
she requested that she earned her degree
I read your book and I'm doing the
article for Court of Harlem oh I'm gonna
talk with you cuz I already talked to
the other folks why she's always refer I
referred to as the widow and not so much
on her own yeah that's a that's a very
good question because I was very
conscious you know the second half a
little bit more than half the book is
really about her life afterwards and I
think that's the substance of her story
in the substance of her persona and her
legacy happened in those years you know
she was very young when she married
Malcolm and she was very she was 30 when
he died he was 39 I think I used the
widow well one is kind of stylistically
to break up you know Betty Betty Betty
Bay and other thing I think consciously
to continue to remind readers of this
how profoundly this identity shaped her
life and shaped her own identity now
her relationship to her widowhood if you
will was not an easy relationship I mean
she struggled with it she struggled to
carve out her own identity and in the
late 60s and early 70s various groups
would call upon her to show up because
having her there they they had like the
you know implicit approval of Malcolm or
the implicit presence of Malcolm she
represented him so powerfully for
instance the Panthers when they were
trying to make a name for themselves in
Oakland I think it's 67 invited her to
the Bay Area and it was a big big deal
because they picked her up from the
airport with their guns and everything
she was scared of death in fact in fact
she
in fact she had fallen asleep she had
fallen asleep on the airplane and when
she woke up and she saw all these men in
the black leather and everything she's
like oh who did come in front of me she
was like she was mad at herself for
having missed whatever you know
celebrity and then she realized they
were there for her so but for her guns
were real I mean Malcolm had taught her
how to use a gun not to protect against
white folks but to protect against the
black people who had already attempted
his life who were hunting him down who
had presumably he believed fire bombed
the house with his babies inside so she
knew about guns not because she wanted
to she'd grown a very middle-class
growing up in an AME Church but this has
had been her experience when she married
Malcolm she had no idea that she was
gonna have to deal with this stuff she
thought she was marrying a minister she
was marrying a minister like anybody
else who marries a pastor of a Christian
Church you think you're gonna be the you
know missus you know of the of the
congregation and she was to some extent
but she also in later years had to deal
with the violent response to Malcolm's
political message you know in so many
different ways so but I think that's an
excellent point because again that
relationship to public widowhood and
what people wanted expected of her was
always tense and it wasn't I think until
the 80s maybe even the early 90s when
for the first time she began to enjoy
some like celebrity she began to get she
was never up there with mrs. King but
she started because of Spike Lee's movie
she got in there to that level by that
time she'd figured out this is how I
want to move and she became a very
forceful determined committed I think
sophisticated not leader but figure she
never considered herself a leader and
she didn't want to be a leader she she
saw what leadership it did to Malcolm
she didn't want to be a leader but she
did want to serve black people she
didn't want to serve in particular black
women black children women of color
around the world so when she travelled
in the world if she did constantly do
the various women's conferences and
particularly in Africa this is what she
wanted to represent and this was in some
ways a similar message that Malcolm you
know similar in the sense of the oh the
the international consciousness and
which is what she always wanted to
stress about Malcolm but in other ways
it was very different it was very much
Betty's own contribution and her own
sophistication you know she went back to
school got her master's got her EDD
studied the organization of afro the
organization of African Unity which is
the organization that Malcolm and
patterned his organization of
afro-american unity after so these were
ideals that were very important to her
and she began to represent them in a
very sophisticated men domestic sphere
and even though it was very limited in
Islam I suppose and his most religions I
mean Christianity to it said also as a
limited domestic sphere but how she
reinvented that after the assassination
when the - that when the twins were in
that daycare and how she kind of went in
and redeveloped I really liked that part
of the story I guess as a you know black
women's activist of sorts not a real
level of faith but on another level
that's a part of her life you never hear
about right I mean I really I really
enjoyed that aspect of and I guess I was
really wanting more biography but it
wasn't the way you have a title is
actually what it is and so I said I
really had to read this and read the
title again so you cannot say what the
book is about so right I really enjoyed
it and you'll be able to read about that
in the late 60s
dr. Shabazz began taking I think our two
babies that the twins to this day care
and I think also probably Camilla who
was like four or five at the time to
this day care probably black
working-class daycare in Mount Vernon
and she began to have a bigger and
bigger role play a bigger and bigger
role in this daycare which is very kind
of experimental and she it was her own
kind of activism started to emerge in
terms of she saw some of the children
acting funny and she alerted the
administrators that it might be lead
poisoning in their buildings she
got some of her friends like Nina Simone
to do concerts on behalf of this daycare
and eventually dr. Shabazz began taking
on more and more kind of civic roles in
terms of looking out for some of the
young girls in Mount Vernon when a lot
of the teenage mothers she had a class
for them so that she kind of considered
her own activism
and it wasn't an activism that was going
to put her in harm's way she wasn't
going to you know catch no bullets
behind but this is was was critically
important to her
and I think that as a as a young brother
who was writing about this story and who
came to the story as I said before you
came in partly because of my attraction
to mountains masculinity and Malcolm's
machismo you know I had to understand
that this is a this is also a critical
part of freedom struggle you know not
only hold not only you know staying at
home and cooking the meals that kind of
thing which is critically important but
also holding the families together
teaching the children passing on
whatever ideals she interpreted her
husband's life is representing to the
babies you know which Malcolm talked
about before he left so it was very
educational for me as well go ahead Ben
thank you for coming how long did it
take for the book to come into fruition
two research processes and everything
behind it it took about five years about
four and a half years it was very tough
because dr. Shabazz had lived so
privately because she had to you know
even at the end of her life when she was
in her late 50s or early 60s and was a
very well-known figure was definitely
part of the black bourgeoisie was a link
was a Delta traveled in very elite
circles knew everybody who was anybody
in black life I mean her address book
anybody you can imagine is in there when
she was getting invited to the White
House for forties under under George
Clinton
I wish I wished it was George Clinton
under Bill Clinton she's still Freudian
slip she still would not discuss
important business over the telephone or
her personal life she never discussed a
personal life anywhere really but
certainly not over the telephone she
always assumed it was tapped she had had
the experience of having her phones
tapped by the FBI and I'm sure she knew
like I said you know well into the 70s
that she was being still being
surveilled by by the by the intelligence
community who knows I mean I from the
records it stopped in like 77 but you
know I mean they don't they only let you
see so much I know lonely let you see it
30 years later that's that's so 30 years
from now who knows what they'll be
uncovering about CIA and crack in our
community who knows what they'll be
uncovering but and that was another kind
of conflict of dr. Shabazz's life
because again she did rise to that level
of prominence she was moving in those
very elite circles certainly in New York
she's very close to David Dinkins first
black mayor of New York but at the same
time she was never gonna forget what the
government had done to her family and to
her husband and she was never going to
forgive it nor was she going to forgive
what Farrakhan of the Nation of Islam
had done you know there was that
reconciliation quote/unquote
reconciliation that she had with
Farrakhan in in 95 I guess or 96 late 95
early 96 at the Apollo in Harlem where
she shook his hand he went to hug her
actually if you look at the tape he went
to hug her and how came out the booty
kind of stuck his body halfway in
between his ended up shaking hand she I
made it clear that she did not want to
hug that man she said I am NOT hugging
that man she said thank you to him they
had this GLAAD planned the whole thing
out beforehand they had
met at LaGuardia Airport in a secret
meeting and Farrakhan had his people
with him and she said hello I thank you
for this was after
kabila her second daughter had been
indicted by the FBI and a very shady
plot by the or very shady case for
plotting the assassination of a fair
akan and it's clear that I mean they do
have her on tape talking with this guy
this Informer the slimy guy who tried to
entrap her so she was talking about her
she was discussing it and I'm not saying
that that the family does not has not
been troubled and though they've been a
lot of troubles but this was really
really a very traumatic episode for dr.
Shabazz because everything she had
fought to save her daughter's from seem
to be coming back you know all the the
FBI all the intrigue all the heartache
of the past seem to be coming back up
you know so even though there were so
many victories and triumphs in her life
and her passage I think out of the
movement and into professional life
mirrors that of so many sisters who came
out of the movement
most of them unsung of course but who
played such a critical role in black
liberation and civil rights movement and
then who had to find a way to enter
professional life find a way to go back
and get degrees so I think dr. Shabazz
represents that struggle and I think
that's why she was for so many women
particularly women of color particularly
single moms she was such a hero because
she represented that struggle that
transition that evolution that struggle
to have your own identity that struggle
to take care of the children to pass on
I you know ideals to them better than
anybody else really and and and in a way
that was in many ways maybe even more I
it's kind of silly to make the
comparison but even more profound than
mrs. King not to take anything away from
mrs. King struggle which is I mean
amazing god bless her but
the depths to which Betty had to climb
out of you know and dr. Betty is I
should say is is amazing and I think so
many sisters recognize that and it
resonated with them way but I I didn't
know the part about her being adopted
either or being taken in by that family
the Malloys that is a very intersting
point cuz when you try to explain how
resilient she was there was no filming
network outside of the - - adoptive
parents that she had there were no
siblings and no cousins that she was
close to and were close to so I think
that really helps emphasize that she had
to really steal within herself some you
know sense of determination for herself
in her children in her future
right what she didn't have half sisters
three half sisters in the Troi area but
I mean like sold her parents were
elderly so they her father had passed
away before Malcolm's assassination and
her mother lived I think until the her
adopted her foster mother then until
like the eighth late 80s I think maybe
the early eighties but she also had been
somewhat estranged from them because
like so many brothers and sisters who
join the nation when you join the nation
back then that meant you know pretty
much breaking ties with your family
because all of a sudden you weren't
Christian no more and and the Malloys
said well you know what's gonna happen
your soul when you die this kind of
thing you know so as much as Islam may
or may not be accepted in the black
community or the nation in Islam in
particular may or may not be accepting a
black community today certainly was much
more foreign or exotic and scary for
Christian black folks back then so yeah
thank you for pointing out whatever
process you had to go through to get the
book published how did you choose your
publisher what was where was that
eventually because I'm especially
concerned about some of the stuff that's
being published right now within for the
african-american community I don't feel
like we're seeing enough water
biographies and biographies and so I was
just wondering what what did you have to
go through to get West it's still very
very seldom do black people write the
lives of black people
so the still vac biographer is is still
a very small group and and I mean I was
very blessed to have this opportunity
when I started doing the research I went
to Arnold Ramprasad who is a very
prominent black biographer who did
Jackie Robinson and Arthur Ashe and it's
not writing a book about Ralph Ellison
and I asked him how do I go about how do
I start you know he sat me down for
hours and talked to me very graciously
but one of the things he said is that
you know there very few black people
that are writing the lives of black
people this is still very immense
amazing
in one sense and I mean as we know black
people read you know white publishers
discovered some time ago that black
people read I think the original I was
actually the original contract was with
a different publishing company in New
Jersey and they wanted I think a kind of
a quick job on dr. Shabazz they had
published a book I think a little a
coffee-table biography of Dinah Ross a
few years back that did really well
Solverson they discovered that that
black people read and that black women
were worthwhile subjects so I think they
wanted something similar for the I
couldn't do something that for dr.
Shabazz her story's too important and
too complex so I actually spent a long
time researching and writing the book
and eventually the contract got bought
out by source books which is an
independent house in Illinois and you
know initially they didn't seem to
certainly they haven't done too many
black books before they were very they
were very good they stayed true to my
vision they didn't cut anything and it
was a very very long manuscript they
wanted it to come in like it and half
this you know tops manuscript pages was
stacked this high you know and the
publishers death but I had to I had to
fight for I had to fight that hard they
really remained true to to my vision so
as far as the prop did I ask you a
question as far as the process yeah it
was a it was a struggle
in terms of getting the interviews and
finding the information because that
Shabazz had lived so privately and also
I was struggling within myself like am i
worthy to do this you know I'm I'm young
and I'm a I'm a man and what what don't
I understand about this woman's story
but I think like I said it was very
educational for me and I think it was a
blessing that a man was able to and a
young man was able to tell this story
because I think it's you really get to
understand a lot about the aftermath of
the struggle both about what real
commitment to the struggle is and about
what happened in the aftermath of the
struggle I talked to the daughters too
often I
I talked to Kabila every now and then I
talked to Camila Camila is the second
daughter and give me others a fourth
daughter every now and then I'll see
Lily after the third daughter because
the Ilyas is up there in Mount Vernon
working for the city I think they like
it
you know you know ask kabila the other
day I said you know what what are you
sisters think and she said uh they think
it's a good book they think you did a
good job now obviously they think the
things that they wish I didn't you know
explore but I was committed to you know
I was trained as a journalist I was
committed to doing an objective
biography while at the same time I'm you
know
clearly it's a sympathetic biography
clearly it came out of my deep love and
admiration for Malcolm and my deep
respect for the struggle for a sister
Betty struggle but you know I deal with
a lot of the crises that she had to deal
with it wouldn't it be absurd to tell
her story and try and sanitize it
because it's a deeply tragic story and I
think a lot of the tragedy even though
in many ways she's unique because you
know how many sisters have sat there and
watched their husband and shot down in
front of their eyes in the way that she
did but there are many sisters who have
lost sons husbands male members of the
family to violence there are many
sisters
who've had to deal with suddenly being a
single mom for so many reasons there are
so many sisters who have had to deal
with after they've raised their own kids
having a Dem raised with their grandkids
which is what she was doing when that
fire killed her so really understanding
her story will teach you a lot about
what sisters have had to deal with you
know in this country in the last however
many years maybe always and other thing
is that when I first started doing it
you know this kind of two ways you as a
young man of my generation coming out of
hip-hop generation look at women almost
like they're invisible where it's just
Malcolm and Martin or it's the strong
black woman who is this kind of like
mythical figure who can leap a building
in a single bound
well I realized that both models are
actually not fair and actually I raised
the true woman sister Betty was strong
dr. bears were strong but she wasn't
always strong and she didn't always want
to be strong she wanted to be vulnerable
a lot of times but she didn't have that
privilege you know I think that she I
think that probably all women and all
men can be as strong as she had to be
but doing so comes along with a great
cost you know and what was that cost
well there was a deep emotional cost
there was a deep spiritual cost
how did her relation how does she
maintain a relationship to God how does
she maintain a relationship with her
daughters and it was really a lot of
struggles you know so you can't just say
oh black women are so strong strong
black women sisters have had to be
strong you know let's look at some of
the reasons why and let's look at some
of the consequences of black women
having to deal with so much of the
burden and also black women who have to
deal with that burden are there
opportunities in our culture in our
community for black women to speak about
their pain to speak about their trauma
and I think for so many different
reasons
dr. Shabazz found that there wasn't you
know I think part of that was
her because although she was trained as
a psychiatric nurse and although she
tried she counseled young sisters that
were dealing with family crises to seek
help to speak out about their pain she
never did and I think part of that
really ate her up very personal
information like okay I haven't I'm with
the Washington afro-american newspaper
in fact the Baltimore office sent me
here so we're doing it for both papers
and congratulations so I just I think I
just opened up just like this real quick
so I could just look at okay and it was
something very unique that I've never
heard anybody else say about about Betty
Shabazz and how when how Malcolm like to
dance whatever yeah I thought that that
was nice and now he was very intimate
how he just like you know he was still
that that Detroit slim guy in the house
but he was Malcolm X in public and the
fact that how he treated her when is
when his friends came over how they had
a certain kind of demeanor right how did
you get that well a lot of that was some
of it was through interview she herself
gave later on cuz she didn't talk about
the marriage at all for years but when
she finally did in different contexts
she had different strategies for
memorializing Malcolm as I called it I
think some of those memories are
exaggerated okay because Malcolm was
never home I'm not saying that they
never danced I'm sure they did I mean
cuz dr. Shabazz could dance and we all
know Malcolm could dance oh and dr.
Shabazz was very soulful and she was
coming out of Motown Detroit and you
know brother Malcolm of course loved
jazz and then so they had that whole
cultural side but again he was a
minister and he was an ascetic minister
I mean you know he was ministry was up
before daybreak great read his six
newspapers had his meals specifically at
a certain time that that Betty had to
cook for him a certain way it was a very
rigid lifestyle I think part of talking
about those memories even though they
might just have been a few and me if she
might have embellished them a little bit
was therapeutic for her you know and I
think that she learned something that
Myrlie Evers I think learned who really
Evers actually wrote the foreword I
think mrs. Evers Williams learned a long
time ago that the more you talk about
this the more you talk about some of
that pain you exercise some of those
demons it's therapeutic you know I'm
saying mrs. King for a lot of different
reasons was never able or willing to be
as candid even though she's written in
her autobiography but mrs. Evans
Williams you know in her I kind of
remember that the latest book or the
second I think it's not her last book of
second or last book checks talks about a
fight that she had with mega where they
actually got into it physically you know
and dr. Betty and mrs. King gasped like
they couldn't believe she had been that
candidate because the unspoken word
among the widows is you know you don't
talk about you know but these were in
many ways beautiful marriages and deeply
strained marriages I mean like you know
I'm single but I imagine all marriages
have both elements and certainly when
someone is this involved in the public
eye and always on the road and this kind
of thing identity because she was there
originally they came through the Nation
of Islam and then after Malcolm died
it's like nobody I mean the you know
that the Islamic community here in
America went through different
transitions they went from a lot of them
one for the Nation of Islam on to
becoming sunni or shia muslims or
whatever and but you never really heard
too much about Betty Shabazz or her
daughters and in our community we just
didn't hear about it really so what was
she I mean what she kind of like she had
to remain a certain way because of who
Malcolm was or who was Betty Shabazz was
she Muslim anymore was he not what was
going on well even before Malcolm's
death after she left the after they had
left the Nation of Islam
well I when Mount my Malcolm converted
to Orthodox Islam when he visited Mecca
and he became our Haj Malik el-shabazz
sister Betty also converted
she actually made her Hajj she visited
went on her pilgrimage a couple of
months after Malcolm's death so she
actually made her hot she fulfilled all
five pillars of Islam she gave arms she
recognized the oneness of Allah she
fasted etc etc etc but she took off her
her head wrap one of the reasons was
that she did not want to look like she
was in the Nation of Islam
she was very bitter to as a nation as
long she didn't want to look like those
sisters another reason was that she was
very independent and she had she lived
by very modern reason reading of the
Quran she did not believe in being
submissive to men nor does the Quran
really said be submissive to men but
that's how you know men interpret it
just like Christian men so and also she
went to church from time to time she
hung out with their Christian
girlfriends she stopped going to mosque
she went to Moscow for many years in New
York but it was never really she never
rigidly I think she maintained a
relationship to Allah throughout her
life I don't see how she could have done
what she did without that but it was a
very personal relationship and it didn't
always manifest itself in ways that
Muslims or non-muslims were comfortable
with you know and she would you know
from talking to people she cuts you out
in a second if she felt like you were
being rude or if you'd violated her and
because she had she built up that
defense mechanism she had to take care
of herself and take care of her and
protect her children and I think part of
that personality was there even before
you know Malcolm talks about how his
parents used to get into it and his
father used to beat his mother well
Malcolm never from what we know put a
hand on on on sister Betty but certainly
they got into it and certainly dr.
Shabazz being an educated woman just
like Malcolm's mother who was a prolific
journalist for Garvey she was very
outspoken so
okay okay do you know what is going on
with her grandson no where is he yeah
well I think right now he's he's I think
right now he's actually still doing time
on something unrelated he is by all
accounts a brilliant
Camus a kid he's a young man now I think
the New York Times recently did did any
I'll see that New York Times article on
him maybe a few months ago he they were
talking about how you know the inmates
in prison I'm not sure where he's doing
time with all the inmates were bringing
him gifts and you know giving a special
treatment because I knew his Malcolm's
grandson but what strikes me when I I
never met the brother I never
interviewed him what strikes me when I
hear about him is that you know I work
with with kids in in Rikers up in New
York with young men and he strikes me as
very similar to those kids in the sense
that he's brilliant he's ambitious he's
misguided he's troubled he's confused
he's hurt he's articulate you know the
kids that I work with in Rikers I just
like this kid so in a sense it's really
one of the many ironies of the Shabazz
story because if you look look at the
autobiography and how Malcolm describes
himself as a young man and how other
people describe Malcolm as a young man
it was quick-witted quit tongue you know
same type of sharp shoe from the hip cat
that I see in Rikers and that little
Malcolm seems to be so the question then
becomes you know how do we deal with
these with these children I think that
dr. Shabazz was trying to answer that
question
like so many grandmothers when she was
tragically killed yeah bunch of kinda
kind of sketchy diagnoses when he was
very young because he had problems even
from the time he's very very small but
they did formally I think diagnosed him
as schizophrenic and and and paranoia
number of different things going on that
some of which is his own mother had
dealt with and you know there's also a
legacy of mental
health issues in a Malcolm side of the
family too so it's very very complex and
of course compounded a hundred times or
a thousand times by all the trauma that
the family has endured so there's still
the daughters are still I think
struggling the ones I talk to still
struggle with a lot of these things and
they're still mourning of course so now
if a fonts me to sign books
Russell Beckford is author of Betty
Shabazz a remarkable story of survival
and faith before and after Malcolm X
it's published by source books visit
source books calm for more information